Megan's making money keep watching to
find out how much she is absolutely
slaying the weekend box office it's only
been a week since 2023 began but one new
movie already seems to have caught
American moviegoers attention the
filming question Megan has been a topic
of conversation ever since the first
trailer for it was released by Universal
Pictures back in October of 2022 the
film's debut trailer went viral and it's
never been hard to see why not only does
the trailer teaser film's premise which
revolves around the creation of a robot
doll named Megan but it also features
one truly absurd laugh out loud scene
where Megan begins to dance in the
middle of a dark off his hallway ever
since that trailer was released Megan
has been shaping up to be the first
noteworthy horror film of 2023 the
anticipation surrounding it only
continue to grow too after it was
revealed that the film was written by a
Kayla Cooper who received similar
attention in 2021 for the bonka
screenplay she wrote for director James
won Supernatural Thriller Legends her
newest film was notably based on a story
that she and one crater together a fact
that made malignant fans only more
excited to check out Megan now just a
few days after Megan hit theaters in the
United States it seems safe to say that
the viral hype surrounding the film was
already started to pay off for it
according to deadline Megan took the
number one spot at the domestic box
office this past Friday by raking in a
total of 11.7 million dollars across
3509 theaters as a result the film is
now expected to earn around 27.5 million
dollars in its opening weekend Avatar
the way of water continues its winning
streak set to rake in somewhere over 38
million dollars in its fourth weekend it
should be noted that Megan managed to
bring in over 300 000 more than James
Cameron's sequel on Friday signaling the
way of waters downward trajectory to
date of Box Office Mojo reporter Juan's
Mega and has already earned a total of
15 million dollars at the worldwide box
office it's domestic performance notably
makes it the first January horror film
to earn more than 20 million dollars in
its opening weekend since Insidious the
last key which ranked in 29.6 million
dollars when it made its debut in
January of 2018. these early box office
total should come as welcome news to
Universal Pictures akayla Cooper 1.
director Gerard Johnstone and the rest
of the creative team behind Megan with
such positive reception at the box
office it would mean the film was
already earned more than double its 12
million production budget in just its
first three days in theaters the film is
in other words already on its way to
performing well enough financially to
Warrant behind the scenes discussion
about the potential sequel that of
course won't happen unless Mega
maintains a strong box office
performance past his first weekend which
remains to be seen for theaters and
Studios however the early success of
Megan also means that the theatrical
experience isn't dying as the film
industry continues to reel from the
challenges presented throughout the last
few years it's fair to suggest that the
first weekend at the 2023 box office was
a success while Avatar's dominance was
sure to continue Megan remained an
unknown quantity even in the face of the
strong viral push the horror film
received thanks to Tick-Tock and other
social media posts James Von's latest
proves that audiences are more than
ready to return to Cinemas for
intriguing and gutsy ideas at least when
it comes to horror 2022 proved to be a
fruitful year for horror projects at the
domestic box office with nope smile and
the black phone all raking in over 90
million dollars a feed star studded
flicks like Amsterdam and Babylon could
barely achieve Megan is just the latest
entry to capitalize on this profitable
Trend as 2023 continues to unravel
itself many in the industry hope that
this year's box office can continue to
grow 2022 rake danger shy of 26 billion
dollars a mighty number albeit 35 below
the
2017-2019 average for now Dragon success
is a good start to 2023 and all eyes are
on what's next the ending of Megan does
open the door for a future sequel with
that in mind what is franchise prospects
will likely depend entirely on his box
office totals after the weekend it seems
safe to say that the film's slow March
toward a sequel has already got enough
to a promising start